j'avais 13 ans ça marchait pas à l'école
j'étais dans le 18e rue ram est à côté
de la goutte d'or entre château rouge la
goutte d'or
mon papa vend des fruits et légumes ma
mère a tout fait elle a tout fait et
j'ai été mauvais j'étais mauvais à
l'école très mauvais donc il y avait
même pas le bac comme projet ma mère m'a
trouviez pas là tout fait j'ai été viré
et allemaal a ouvert le journal
et à cette époque là quand on ouvrait le
journal je vous parle de ça en 1966 donc
il ya 66 ans ou tous en selle en plus
important yabon cherche apprenti
coiffeur aucune idée de ce qu c est
coiffeur enfin ma mère à la une génie
elle a vu avenue matignon une matignon
ce nom un quartier très chic et ma mère
elle venait de l'assistance publique
mais au lieu de haïr les richards event
un stade bien faut mieux qu'ils soient
placés là là c'est un moment essentiel
de ma vie où je suis passé des pauvres
aux riches
ça veut pas dire que j'étais passé
d'être pauvres et riches mais voilà et
là on m'a présenté un monsieur qui
ressemblait à georges brassens qui est
un grand coiffeur qui s'appelait jacques
france et ce monsieur m'a dit vous aimez
la coiffure
jamais il n'avait jamais entendu parler
de ma vie du mot coiffure et il me dit
parce que moi la première chose si je
vous prends faudra pour faire pousser
vos cheveux et c'était un miracle dans
ma tête parce que c'était les premiers
temps des beatles
je me faisais plein pour la première
fois on ne va pas me couper les cheveux
et j'ai déliré en disant je suis un
dingue de la mise en plis vous savez ça
c'est ma passion le matin je me lève
j'ai envie de faire des prochaines j'ai
envie de hilali 1000 et exalté jeune
homme tim ou donner le rôle e apprenti
coiffeur donc un des plus grands moments
de ma vie ça a été de prendre cet
autobus avec ma maman
[Musique]
je suis coiffeur j'ai 16 ans 17 ans mais
je danse whisky à gogo avec paul pas
signé bensimon même simon a été très
important dans ma vie c'est un bonhomme
qui m'emmène à angoulême il dit il faut
que tu animes la boîte donc je met à
danser
j'avais beaucoup observé les blacks je
danse beaucoup moins bien que james ward
mais toutes les petites femmes et là il
ya un mec qui me regardent
il s'appelle philippe labro il me dit
est ce que tu veux faire de la
figuration dans mon film
boum tout peut arriver je quitte la
coiffure pour devenir début comédien et
après je suis retourné à la coiffure
parce que ça n'a pas pu brancher
jamais de la vie rêvée de quoi c'est le
mot comédiens j'aime pas ce que ça
voulait dire j'étais coiffeur getti
coiffeur chez nous on n'avait qu'une
ambition à notre époque fumer du shit
aller à katmandou et finir en iran tu
vois ce que je veux dire je suis seul
sur l'autoroute
je n'arrête pas de penser veut vous
amuser sans doute de ce que je suis à
pied vous beaucoup ça c'est antoine qui
était une adaptation accessible de bob
dylan
on était nourrie de katmandou d'antoine
de bob dylan pour les plus pointus et on
rêvait qu'un truc pas de faire de
carrière
eric rohmer grommerch pas tous qui
s'était à ce que moi mon papa il
m'emmenait pas voir des films d'eric
rohmer c'est parce qu'un prof c'était un
immigré italien et grand mère me
convoque et me donne un rôle dans je ne
perds ça devient très bizarre tout d'un
coup j'ai un deuxième rôle je demanderai
rien rohmer mme me me prend on me dit
que c'est un des plus grands metteurs en
scène de la nouvelle vague et à partir
de là les agents de comedia disent à mon
avis tu réussiras jamais parce que tu
n'es pas sexuée tepa sexy et un phrasé
bizarre on sait pas si tu es homo hétéro
alors fait plutôt du théâtre parce
qu'aussi matra jamais de carrière je
suis amer à vous n'êtes pas encourageant
en somme
mais non parce que t'as vu ta gueule et
je me suis retrouvé avec jean laurent
cochet ça c'est le mans un moment
essentiel de ma vie c'est la découverte
c'est comme si j'avais découvert que
l'un gould d'où un mec qui aime le
reggae bob marley ou un mec qui aime le
rythm and blues james brown ou un mec
comme la musique classique bach ou
mozart et lâche tombe sur le plus grand
professeur qui incarne le répertoire qui
incarne la difficulté est là j'ai 24 ans
je fume beaucoup de chic et et là
j'arrête le shit j'avais tout parce que
j'ai découvert
je sais qu'il y a un but le but c'est
devenir un acteur c'est à dire un
comédien c'est à dire quelqu'un qui va
se confronter à racine à corneille à la
molière ou rap à tous j'ai découvert la
vocation que tous dès que quelque chose
m'intéressait que ça demanderait
beaucoup de sacrifices eh ben c'est
comme un homme qui rentre dans les
ordres
j'ai eu la révélation jeudi et ben voila
j'ai enfin depuis j'ai 24 ans c'est la
première fois que j'ai envie de faire
quelque chose
[Musique]
ça s'est passé dans les années 70 et
pendant vingt ans j'ai fait des choses
mais au cinéma ça marchait pas bien jour
quelqu'un m'a donné un scénario qui
s'appelait la discrète
c'était en 1990 vous étiez pagny c'est
hélas ça a été un film qui tout d'un
coup que quitté i cry tous qui étaient
mes défauts pour les uns sont devenus
mes qualités et là toute ma vie a changé
parce que tout d'un coup j'ai fait des
entrées et j'ai eu un style un petit peu
littéraire un petit peu qui a rencontré
le grand public est là tout change
ce que ça a changé c c'est c'est comme
un livre cap a été édité donc tu es très
malheureux but on a compté dit voilà
être reconnu par le public c'est ne plus
être un manuscrit qui souffrent c'est un
manuscrit qui devient un bouquin dans
une édition
là je demande à brûle de faire un effort
intellectuel roland barthes disait
qu'est ce qu'un manuscrit
c'est un paquet de désir est évidemment
j'ai envie de répondre disait roland bas
qu'est-ce que je peux faire du désir de
l'autre
sinon d'être panique est un acteur qui
n'est pas reconnu c'est un paquet désir
qui fait chier tout le monde et comme on
se dit oh là là voilà le chieur qui est
besoin d'être émises quant est un acteur
reconnu tu as été édité tpu menaçant
parce que cette petite folie que tu as a
été a été identifié et est devenu un
produit donc tu n'es plus fous ces
brutes et moi j'étais votre serviteur
fabrice luchini en brut
à bientôt